now your voice is so unusual your
delivery i mean now there's a lot of
people i sense who imitate your style
but back when you were looking for a
record deal
i bet you got rejected a lot i got
rejected all the time you did i sent a
lot of songs out the there was i think
there were about 10 songs that i had
that weren't on jaggy little pill that i
just wrote i called them the interim
songs yeah they're getting the whistle
wet songs right and then i started
writing i think perfect and you ought to
know and i sent those both of those out
to a few people who were not interested
you've answered this question a million
times but we have to get to the bottom
of it
you wrote that song about dave coulier
from full house
people talk about who that song's about
and they will continue to and i never i
never confirm or affirm who it's about
and i never will you kidding me well i
say never and i should really shouldn't
say never because i may very well one
day do it but you've never reve who how
did his name even come up do you know
that guy you did it yeah he did that he
dated him yes i did
so when did dave coulier when did you
start dating him
i was
19. 19. i was singing at an all-star
hockey game i was doing the national
anthem and he was playing and you were
that worked up about him that you'd
write a song i feel it is about him you
know who told me who told you stamos
john stamos yeah he told me that too
the thing is there was no one in the
studio when i wrote that song so no one
actually knows
and not that i'm just doing it
gratuitously for the sake of mystery but
i didn't write it with the intention of
recriminating her
you